movies have been my passion for as long
as I can remember I feel most
comfortable when I'm making them
watching them or talking about them and
I found a home on YouTube for many years
doing that ever since 2009 when I
started my channel and today I have over
1 million subscribers and it's been a
very crazy and strange journey that I'm
still surprised at pretty much every day
I'm floored by the support that I've
received and I know that without all of
you I would still be working on a school
bus because of you guys I am working to
achieve my dreams and your support over
all these years is something I'm so
thankful for and a lot of people say
that like yeah I'm really thankful that
you support me but I really do mean it
and I've tried to say it in every single
one of my videos for a very long time
you guys are the best and I mean that
but if you've been watching my videos
since the early days in 2009 you know
that I did not start my channel because
of money in fact I didn't even know that
you could make money on YouTube for a
while
and back in the day on YouTube you had
to apply for partnership you couldn't
just be instantly monetized and I didn't
get partnership for the first few years
of my youtube career I didn't see a dime
for all that time and I still reviewed
new releases every single weekend
because I enjoy it I love it it's
something that I'm passionate about
movies it's what I love and even after I
got partnered I still couldn't fully
support myself for at least a few more
years after that and so YouTube has
never been about the money I've been
writing short stories since elementary
school I've been making short films with
my friends since I was 14 years old
this is my life but since my channel has
become more successful it's become a
legitimate full-time job it's awarded me
a lot of amazing opportunities like
going to the Critics Choice Awards and
being a member of the broadcast Film
Critics Association and writing a first
book called the film buffs bucket list a
second book in which myself and many
other authors collaborated to create
anime impact and a lot of side work goes
along with my youtube channel I'm always
trying to keep the channel consistent
and the quality up-to-date but at the
same time I want to make short films
I want to make feature films eventually
this is my real passion this is where my
heart really lies filmmaking in 2017 I
shot my first official short film and I
had the time of my life I have rarely
felt as good as I did when I was on that
set even if it was stressful even if we
were running out of time it was good
stress it was a blast and I have ideas
for more short films too this year that
I'm gonna be working on one this summer
I'm already in the writing process with
a friend of mine this is something I
want to continue to do and YouTube is
continuing to be a place where earning
revenue that you deserve is getting more
difficult the ad pocalypse rampant D
monetization issues and fraudulent
claims across the board for not just me
but countless other people many artists
around the entire world are dealing with
these issues and it's becoming clearer
and clearer that earning revenue and
supporting yourself on YouTube is going
to get increasingly difficult and since
so many of my fellow creators have
already started a patreon this is
something that's been a long time coming
but what I want to do is make sure that
everything on my youtube channel that
you have all enjoyed for free for all
these years stays that way my anime
reviews my new releases my hilarious
''tis my analysis of other films all of
these things are going to stay there
patreon is entirely optional to you this
is not a requirement if you'd like to
support my work I appreciate that and I
am so grateful to you but this is a
chance for me to do a few extra fun
things I've always wanted to do and
share it specifically with patrons here
things like commentary tracks or a
podcast these are things I've always
kind of wanted to do but I've been
searching for the right time to do it
and I think this is that time I want to
keep my tears relatively low I don't
think you need to spend that much money
on
me if you want to support my work I'm so
thankful and I appreciate it but for me
this is a way that I can continue to
pursue my dreams outside of YouTube and
filmmaking and in writing things I want
to do that I don't necessarily have the
time to do for instance I self-financed
auditorium 6 my first professional short
that I worked on last year that I've
mentioned before and it became evident
that I cannot keep doing that it was a
serious strain on our finances and I
would like to find ways to be more
creative and to share things with you
guys that allows me to pursue these
dreams and not be so concerned with the
YouTube circling the drain
with their terrible communication issues
with their creators and I have one more
dream that I've always wanted to achieve
but I didn't really know the right time
the right place and I have finally
decided to go forth with doing that and
I am currently attending the Los Angeles
Film School working towards my
bachelor's degree in digital filmmaking
and I'm so excited about that I think in
the back of my mind I always wanted a
film degree but I just didn't know if it
was the right time and I'm currently
going forth with trying to do that and I
have you guys to thank for that
all of the people over the years who've
messaged me or who have come up to me in
person to tell me that they're going to
college because of this channel
man you guys made me want to go so I am
currently working towards that and
college combined with short films and
writing and books and the YouTube
channel and film criticism I'm married I
have a house I have a lot of stuff on my
plates
I am constantly busy and I just want to
say thank you even if you don't feel
like donating to the patreon that's
perfectly fine it's totally optional to
you everything on my channel will always
be free but thank you for even
considering it thank you for your years
of support and I hope to see what I can
do on this platform because I'm totally
new to all this so let's see where this
goes you guys are the best thank you so
much as always for watching and I hope
to see you guys here on patreon